you know i'm just making assumptions
based on the promo material i've seen
thus far but
it feels like a passing of the torch
type of situation to the kids
in particular but i want to see you kind
of get into the action
as well and i'm just wondering is this
role going to give you the opportunity
to be
more than just like i guess the cookie
cutter mom in the film
yeah that was certainly one of the
things i was afraid of when i first was
approached about it
i think of dee wallace in et who was a
wonderful actress who then sort of
became
well she actually went on had a really
interesting life but you know she became
sort of the
the franchise mom and i thought about
that
but jason is smarter than that jason
is the next generation and he wrote a
lot of fun for all of us
and it was one of the reasons i said yes
to it um you know she actually has a
personality a sense of humor and she
does get in on the action
and that was really fun for me i mean
i'm a ghostbuster basically
which is insane i grew up with that
movie i'm gonna be hearing that song in
every interview for the rest of my life
it's my obituary movie
you